foreign
would have worked financially but it
requires like signing legal to contract
no I personally I personally was not
okay with that my wife
no no no no no no no okay don't be
insane no it sounds crazy I don't enter
into legal contracts with loved ones
[Music]
hey what's going on this is John with
the Dr John deloney show
I got papers flying everywhere I'm so
glad that you are with us
the show about marriage and parenting
and relationships your mental and
physical health
School whatever you got going on in your
life I'm here to walk alongside Jim I'm
John deloney and for 20 years I've been
sitting with people when the wheels have
fallen off I'm trying to figure out what
do I do next
and I've experienced it myself
um I've I just have
dedicated my life to entering into the
fire when the buildings When the Smoke
starts coming out so
I want to first thank you
um for the honor of getting to sit with
you while you're struggling and you keep
tuning in and giving us your most
precious resource which is your time and
asking great questions and sending in
notes and letters I'm just so grateful
for the show's continued growth response
if you want to be on the show give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's 1844-693-3291
or go to John deloney.com ask and here's
the purpose of this show
once you have a better marriage
I want you to get a handle on your
physical and mental health I want you to
get some truth about what's going on
with Mental Health crisis in this
country and there's just so much
nonsense out there so many charlatans
out there so
um
quit my entire
professional trajectory to come sit here
and be a YouTuber in a podcast just to
start putting some kind of Truth out
there because it's Madness Stone Madness
um and so I'm grateful that you've
joined us
um hey a couple of uh housekeeping
things first thing is
um I got some notes this morning on the
viewership of the show it is astounding
Millions
of you guys are tuning in watching Clips
listen to the shows
unbelievable and nobody's hitting the
Subscribe button the the guy who runs
all the metrics was like this is the
strangest account because it continues
to accelerate in such a bananas
b-a-n-a-n-a-s way
um so please take one second hit the
Subscribe button it means the world to
to me to every and to people who've
never heard the show okay so hit the
Subscribe button hit the follow button
the like button the thumbs I I don't
know how the internet's work hit all
those buttons
um and
I love getting mail with all my heart I
love getting mail it's it's literally my
favorite thing and I sit by some other
folks who have shows and nobody gets
mail and it's so great it just makes me
feel like a middle school kid all over
again getting letters
but I got this one the other day if
you're watching this on YouTube you can
see it it's just a pink letter
and there was no return address it just
says the word cheater on it and then
underneath it it says thank you for this
piece p-e-a-c-e
exclamation point that's it and at first
I thought
somebody accusing me of B I don't I
don't think I've ever I don't think I'm
a cheater and then I realize I actually
I realized I don't know what this means
so if you're gonna send things to us
give me a little more context because
otherwise I Think You're a murderer or I
don't know what's happening but cheater
thank you for this piece do you ever
wrote this you are welcome you are
welcome and please do not put Anthrax in
an envelope and mail it to me all right
okay so call in an audible yes is this
you did you say no I did not no Kelly do
you need to tell us something no okay
okay all right but it's a ten dollar
sale one t or two T's one t but okay are
you done I'm done all right thanks
um it's a ten dollar sale because it's
May and this year for the first time the
cards are in there oh the questions for
humans questions for humans are on the
ten dollar sale so I thought in honor
that we would do a question oh and I had
picked one let's do it so everybody in
the control room and John you can start
what is your go-to gas station snack
almost no I mean come on yours has got
to be gummies I've got I gotta yeah yeah
occasionally I'll get a Snickers bar
just because uh but they're usually
mindless bags of gummy candies or jelly
beans yeah I I've got a like a
particular hankering for Albanese lately
they're just the best black Forester
better I they're black force is good but
inside the Black Forest is where the
castle of Albanese lives that's what I
think all right so what do you think
Jenna uh my go-to is always the Fritos
the honey barbecue twists oh they're so
good oh I bet your breath is a delight
exactly yes but they're so good it's
just a delight all right excellent Joe
Butterfinger and a boy you get it all
over you no
you are a clean eater aren't you yes I
am not I'm not
um mine has three parts
skull and
Colt 45 and some Copenhagen please I'm
Kelly Daniels all right no I wish you
were kidding me
um a Yoo-hoo only time I drink is on a
road trip Yoo-hoo yep hi because we're
seven exactly only on a road trip
um Chex Mix
and you're 12 you're seven years old and
uh peanut M M's
wow unless I'm at Bucky's and then it's
a whole different story well Bucky's is
like it's a universe yes it is it is
like I don't yes
it's like a free opium clinic for
somebody who's struggling it's like I
walk in and it's like oh you think you
want gummy candies how about a cowboy
hat and a live raccoon and all the food
you would ever want to eat a brisket
sandwich and a pony yeah while you're
here we're gonna we're gonna put a bed
uh in your car for whatever dude we're
gonna re-roof your house we're Bucky's
it's incredible
Andrew what do you do
normally I go for like peanut butter M
M's I'm simple
I I wish I was you
like we hung out the other night and I
thought I bet
he's much nicer to himself than I am to
me like I just wish I was in your head
for a season seems like it's like a
calmer place
no
yeah sometimes he's like yes I think so
except when I'm thinking about Merc
getting in the cabin and
they come in there never mind all right
excellent
um questions for humans ten dollar sale
go to John deloney.com pick him up
dude they will change your family and
your marriage and your relationship with
your kids little tools to help people
connect it's awesome all right let's go
to Jen in Seattle Jin's been waiting
forever what's up Jen
hi Dr John I'm so
spoke I'm good so you've got to hear you
got to hear how bad I am at making ads
and all the stuff you got to hear all
the sausage made so way to go thanks for
I I kept thinking it's a fun perspective
at some point you're just gonna be like
I I'm I'm out I hang up hey but here's
the thing I always say on this show like
I'm not very good at this and I know it
sounds like I'm being self-deprecating
but you got to hear like oh you're not
that good at this all right you got to
hear it which is kind of awesome the
other night I was in a uh
uh this band under oath came I missed
them when they were popular 15 years ago
and so I went to the show it was sold
out it was Mayhem and this guy stops me
in the mosh pit
and he's like oh you're for real you
actually go to these shows and I was
like yeah did you think I didn't go this
evidently people thought I had this big
anyway so you can see I'm not that good
at the radio Jen so I'm glad that you've
hung in there with us so what's up
what's going on
okay
um so my husband and I have been
together since we were 16. we are both
34 now Rose was it like Dawson's Creek
like I don't want to wait how'd y'all
meet no in high well in Junior High
um uh and so yeah he was he came into my
school in eighth grade and we were sort
of like just saw each other you know how
awkward Middle School junior high is and
but the new boy came and you were like
like sites lasered in
just just right off the bat he was
really nice
did you have braces I did oh so great
like that's so amazing I always wanted
like a childhood Crush that became my
lifelong love didn't work out that way
for me but congratulations okay so it's
not always as cute as you would think I
was gonna say this may be a disaster so
I'm sorry if I'm just setting you up
here but all right go ahead
so we've been together since we were 16.
we're both 34 now we've been married for
12 years this year we have three little
kids and I don't know why but so there's
never been any infidelity any any issues
we've never cheated neither of us are
cheaters my husband has very high moral
standards specifically with our
relationship and just in his life in
general but
for some reason I've always felt really
insecure when he's around other women
and it just it's really been coming to a
head recently for some reason
um I mean admittedly uh I don't have
fantastic self-worth I grew up with an
alcoholic father and a narcissistic
mother and I you know I've been really
digging into that therapy Jim I'm
laughing not because
that was incredible that was incredible
incredible
um self-awareness you know yes yes it's
it's hey that is not this country's
strong suit so well done well done yeah
um so if you if you can honestly rule
out infidelity and so when somebody
comes and says this to me the first
thing I always say is what does your gut
tell you and if you can say my gut tells
me he's a great guy like there's not
some I'm not overriding some innate
signal that my body's picking up on the
Universe
um
then the issue is clearly and I say this
with all love and respect it's nothing
to do with him it has everything to do
with you
yes right I can say with a thousand
percent like I would be completely and
utterly shocked if I ever found out
anything okay like I I can really
confidently say yeah so tell me what is
it gonna sound so cheese ballie tell me
what your body does
when he
is coming home from work and he's and
you're like what are you doing like well
my last meetings with so and so and so
and so and she's beautiful what does
your body do
oh
of the anxiety like my body gets really
shaky and my heart starts racing and all
the thoughts start going that I'm trying
to just keep the lid on that jar
yeah what are the thoughts
she's you know I'm a stay-at-home mom I
run our our business we run our business
together actually and so I run our
business and and I've been to stay at
home mom my oldest is going to be 10
this year and I just don't put in the
effort I used to because I'm here all
the time and so what does that mean what
does that mean what does that mean you
don't put in the effort and what and
looking pretty and you know right here
okay yeah so my to my parents and so I'm
like okay well she's prettier than me
and she probably doesn't have as much
baggage so she's probably easier going
than I am and you know why wouldn't he
you know even entertain the idea because
that's a you know an easier path like
she's nice and she's pretty and she's
you know successful and has these
Ambitions and all this stuff and it just
really starts
setting in even though I know that's not
how he feels I can't stop those thoughts
it's insane
um it's not insane
the good news is your body's working
great
the bad news is it's running an old
script
okay
um
one point of clarification is there a
particular person you've zeroed in on or
is this women Universal
mostly universal
um so we
so my husband's an electrician we have
our own business and we just hired we're
small we're baby business still but we
just hired our first employee and she's
a trainee and it's a woman which for the
trades is not super common
um and she's fantastic I never I was a
part of the hiring process she was the
best candidate and I saw it as an
opportunity for growth for me because
I've never I I've always hated this in
our entire relationship so I'm like you
know what I don't want to shortchange
our business and I want to grow
she's great I don't get any weird vibes
from her like I'm gonna you know she's
not gonna Hand That Rocks the Cradle me
at least I don't that's not the vibe I
get you know and so
um
yeah she's I mean she's tall and she's
beautiful and she has a great attitude
and she's being taught by him which my
husband is a teacher like he loves he
loves teaching and so like she's out
there with him day in Day Out hours on
end in the same truck working side by
side with him and so right now
there hasn't really been a specific
person before then it's just kind of a
general sense and now it's definitely
amped up and I'm just trying to work
through it okay
um all right a couple of things here
we're gonna start all the way back and
then we're going to land to right now
okay okay
um I'm gonna make myself a quick note
here all right so
the child of an alcoholic
and the child of a narcissist
that is somebody surrounded by two
people
who are using the child
as their point of gravity
which means everything you accomplish
not love because it's it's not what
you're getting
but you accomplish stability through
performance
through what you can do for them
right
yeah
and that carries all the way through
your life and so when you see yourself
as a performer
and then life happens you gain some
weight you are chasing 15 kids around a
farm you're running out of business just
life happens
um
you begin the same judgment metrics
or what you apply regardless of the
situation
because there's still a six-year-old
little girl saying God what is so
beautiful about that bottle
that that makes it prettier than me
what is it about me that my mom keeps
using me as a scorecard for how well
she's doing in the world why is it my
job to make sure she's regulated I I
right and so yeah you take that
scorecard because your mom and dad were
supposed to be the only two people on
the planet
that didn't do that and they did our
teachers do it our coaches do it our
friends do it that's life our bosses do
it that's life
but not Mom and Dad not them two
yeah
and they said if you're going to be in
relationship with us this is how you're
gonna dance and you took that card and
you tattooed it on your heart and now
you're a mom you're a business owner
you're a wife you're a best friend and
you're trying to use that same that same
card
so here I'm trying to think of like a
non-lame example but um
um
let me think of like a baseball player
um I'll use a baseball player for my
childhood Craig Biggio came in he was a
catcher but he's really really fast
coming in um when I was a little kid and
he played for the Astros and so in a
couple of years they moved him from
being a catcher to be in a second
baseman to preserve his legs
and then he played forever and over the
course of history he got stronger and he
got his I call it his dad's strength his
start the lawnmower with one pole and he
stopped being judged on how fast he was
he started being judged on how he could
get clutch hits how he never missed
Ground balls how he was a great teammate
and then as even the physical it became
he's a great he's a clubhouse leader
we're going to keep him on a few more
years even though his skills have
diminished because he's leading these
young folks
and so the metric by which they judged
him continued to change and evolve with
him
because that it makes rational sense but
kids who grew up in traumatic households
stamp themselves with one scorecard okay
so you are gonna have to learn to teach
yourself and you're gonna have to be
honest and open with your husband and
teach him
I've got to learn a new way of of
um seeing myself in the world
and it used to be as a performer and
here's what's going to be hard you've
half of his life you've been a performer
too
right and that means you may have agreed
to things in the bedroom you weren't
super down with but you want to be you
want to be the cool wife and you may be
doing things with kids that you don't
really love but he wants you to do it
and so it's like okay we'll just
it's gonna change the dynamic of your
house as you begin to develop autonomy
and say here's what I want here's what I
need that's why both of you are going to
have to commit to okay the marriages we
knew it we're going to put a purity into
that it got us this far it's it can't it
can't move forward or it's going to
implode because I can't continue to
score myself with these same metrics
that I used when I was seven and that my
mom and dad who were sick used on me to
be the wife and the mother and the
business owner that we need to be moving
forward does this make sense
yeah okay
and
I think this is me it's going to be very
unpopular with the internet crowd so do
not read the YouTube comments actually
you can read them because you're gonna
be about me
I do think
um y'all are playing with fire
okay I think there's something to be
said for some accountability
or let me put it this way I would not be
comfortable
hiring a single female to drive around
with me for nine hours a day just us too
working side by side for the future for
a hundred different reasons
and I trust myself
right I don't know what she's gonna say
I don't know what someone's gonna accuse
us of I don't know what impact this is
going to have on my wife I don't know if
this is going to impact it's gonna have
on my business
I don't know any of those factors and I
get that there's an innate
um I don't call it sexism but I don't
want to ever want gender to I want to
hire the best person for the job right
so it may be that in this season we're
gonna hire two people
we're gonna hire two people
and it's going to cost us a little more
money and we're it but it's going to be
worth it in the in the long long run
and if we take a hit for a couple of
years and train them up right and how
we're gonna take care of customers and
the kind of quality of work we do then
it's going to expand your employee base
but I think there's a both and here okay
I want you to know you're not insane
okay nobody nobody well that's not true
very very very few happily married
people
wake up one day and they're like I'm
gonna go have an affair this is not what
happens the number one reason people
have an affair is access
just happens
and so it's not something it's it's a
and and it's stunning how many people
have great marriages and this thing
happens right and so it's it's not like
somebody's fault or it's because of this
because that's a Hollywood reality is
like it it just it just happened so I
think there's something to be said for
sitting back and being smart
and or
yeah I'll leave that to you and your
husband and your business to figure that
out but in yours in my situation at my
house I would hire two people even if I
couldn't afford it I would figure out
how to hire two and that's for as much
for her protection as it is for
um for for him for your marriage for
everybody
I just think there's a wisdom there
um and in a rush to and I think it's a
good rush in a rush for equality we've
sometimes thrown out common sense
and I wish that wasn't the case but
that's just reality
um so I tell you that all that to tell
you a couple of things number one
continue to see your counselor because
you got to deal with the childhood stuff
it's real and it's heavy and it's legit
okay I want you to know you're not nuts
the second thing is
um I want you to begin to feel your body
as it begins to take off on you
and I want you to this is going to be a
pain if you will do this for one month
two months maybe four months if you will
continue to do this to write down every
time it takes off on you
please take the time to write it down
it's gonna be a pain in the butt
but it's the way you're going to teach
yourself to create some space between
your body taken off on you and
those thoughts that come next you got to
start challenging those thoughts the
third thing is I want you and your
husband to have a some sort of retreat
where y'all can say okay we're going to
reimagine our marriage where we want it
to look like we got two kids we got a
small business we're trying to make
these things work here we are
we've done six months here in this new
job I'm not comfortable with this I'm
super comfortable with this I just feel
like we're setting our family up for a
weird thing here or a weird thing there
um
whatever's going on in the world so
and just so you know my wife and I did
this with my job we're six months into a
new job you're on the road a lot you're
traveling you've got these weird writing
hours now you're writing at 4am and at
two in the morning
so five six months in how is everything
two years in how is everything and in
next week I think or the week after
we're doing it again like we are now I
just hit send on another manuscript okay
we gotta recalibrate this thing because
our marriage is different now again so
that's an ongoing conversation that
needs to happen needs to happen and you
can ask some of those questions like
what do you need from me in this season
and let him be honest with you about
what he needs and then you can say okay
here's a list not one that I'm imagining
not a performance schedule that I'm
supposed to be keeping up with but he
told me exactly what he needs from me
and I want you to be honest honest
honest and tell him here's what I need
from you here's what I need from you
I don't know that you can do this
without a family counselor without a
marriage counselor and I would I think
that would be super good use of your
time into your money and you're worth
all of it all of it all of it stay on
the line I'm going to send you a copy of
own your past change your future in fact
I'm missing you two and you and your
husband can both read it together
um I think that would be fantastic for
both of you to give give each of you a
common language as you head into this
new season I think that'd be awesome
um thank you so much for being brave
thank you so much for the call your
body's working as it should and
trying to keep you safe and it's trying
to run an old script and what it used to
keep you safe the way it used to keep
you safe it's gonna mess things up
moving forward so let's get a new script
moving forward I'm so grateful for you
Jen we'll be right back
[Music]
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go to Jason
and Michigan what's up Jason
hey John thanks for having me you got it
brother what's up man
um so first of all uh I I sorry if I
Stumble over my words I'm very nervous
hey I Stumble and I'm not even nervous I
Stumble all the time you're good man
you're in good company so what's up so
this is this is a little long-winded uh
I was hoping that you could help uh me
and my wife uh
do something
um let's do it and when I when I tell
you this uh I just want you to know that
uh me and my wife are very much people
Pleasers and we don't like
confrontations so um you called the
right guy yeah awesome uh I have a
family member that I was on the phone
with early early this morning
trying to encourage a significant
confrontation that they need to have in
their life and so I love a good
confrontation so let's do it awesome uh
so we have we have come across a
financial issue that may drive us out of
state
um we told my in-laws the other day and
as soon as they got back to their house
uh without us knowing they started to
put together a financial plan for us
what happened what happened
uh so um we uh unfortunately the day
okay costs and uh tuition debt and all
that stuff it's too much for us right
now so we have to like we're planning on
just kind of like selling a home and
kind of using those proceeds the set of
options that maybe staying with my
parents down in uh in North Carolina for
a little bit to kind of reset
um that's that's kind of what was going
on
so you have a lot of debt and you own a
home you're thinking about selling the
home paying off everything and just kind
of getting control delete from zero
exactly yeah so we don't owe anyone
anything and why North Carolina is there
you have jobs there uh my family uh
lives there we do not have jobs there
yet but I'm looking
okay and so you told
basically you told your in-laws hey we
we don't have we've got more bills than
we do income the job prospects here
we're not gonna be able to earn our way
out in this community plus the cost plus
whatever
yeah and I I do have a nice career job
right now
um but again I I
with the amount of money we oh I can't
make enough soon enough
um can I can I tell you that it also
sounds like you want to get out of this
part of the country
you're a genius uh I do actually okay so
I was already playing that in the future
but listen listen listen
well before we even get to the Crux of
your question when you have these kind
of conversations with in-laws and with
with other people be 100 honest
okay
like I want to move away from this town
too
okay you see what I'm saying sure and
that way people don't swoop in and try
to solve all of your problems because
they don't know all your problems they
just know the one that you put on the
table which is well we're really
struggling with our air conditioner so
we're gonna sell the house and it's like
suddenly there's repairman at your house
that you didn't even hire and it's like
well also I hate the house and our
marriage is crumble it right there's all
the other things going on
um okay so you want to get home and be
around your family is your wife in on
that
uh she followed it and we had a
discussion in the past about it and we
kind of we kind of uh got to the point
where it's like hey like if we're gonna
make that move that we got to make sure
that uh it's for good reason and that
we're kind of set up uh appropriately
like having jobs and all that stuff do
not move without a job okay exactly yeah
and that's what that's what we're
planning to do not moving without a job
okay all right so um you tell her
in-laws and they start making Financial
plans for you what does that mean
uh so uh so they they came up with this
this plan uh what's uh their plan was
essentially like a chart of our pros and
cons and also they created like a
color-coded chart of like our mental
health and our happiness no no
absolutely not no they get no vote on
that zero run run go to go today I just
told you to don't go without a job go
right now
yeah that's that's yeah exactly what I'm
getting to and so their plan is
essentially uh their plan would work
financially but it requires like signing
legal to contract no my person I
personally was not okay with that my
wife
no no no no no no
don't be insane no I I don't like this
sounds crazy I don't enter into legal
contracts with loved ones
I shake hands or I give the money away
or I say no
yes that was my my gut instinct and I
guess that comes to my uh and also like
currently uh and to give them peace of
mind we're also sharing like in-depth
finances no no no no no they don't your
job isn't to give them peace of mind
that's not your job that's their job
they're grown-ups they're the parents
their job is to go figure out their own
peace of mind not to use y'all to try to
get it yeah I'm trying to like you know
make a decision for my for my family and
it's like it's hard for it's hard to
consider them into that I'm trying to
block that out yes they don't get a vote
yeah so it comes to my questions here uh
Are We Wrong to believe that uh that
they have too much involvement in our
lives and finances is it best if we tell
them that we love them but we don't need
their approval to make decisions and
asking and asking for all this
information kind of makes us feel like
we can't be trusted or we that we can't
support ourselves um so hold on hold on
that's what you told them
um I that's what we're trying to figure
out how to you told them that
you told them that we have to get rid of
our home because we can't make enough
money to survive in this part of the
country and they probably said ah we're
calling bullcrap on that we see how you
spend your money we see how y'all live
and when you told them that and you also
didn't say and we just want to move we
want a new adventure we're going to move
down south where it's cheaper where we
can keep more of our paycheck we're
going to do X Y and Z like fill in the
blank why who cares why I want to go
fishing every weekend and you can't do
that up here I'm tired of the cold
whatever reason you only get by my
family whatever you want to do but you
didn't tell them that you invited them
into a conversation where you said we're
struggling so much we have to get rid of
our house
and you have to understand for our
parents generation getting rid of your
house was everything
and so you told them but essentially
we're about to be destitute and we're
going to move in with somebody else's
parents
and they swooped in to say whoa whoa
whoa whoa
right so you invited them in they're
kind of like a vampire you open the door
and you said come on in and then they
start biting everybody and you're mad
that they're biting y'all invited them
in yeah and you didn't tell them the
whole story when they came in
yeah because in the past they said hey
you can't don't make don't make
decisions based on emotion just make it
also like just the straight numbers
and um and so we're trying to we're just
kind of leading in with the numbers but
it's it's starting to feel like they're
kind of coming in with some emotions too
so yeah of course they are anyone who
says hey never use emotion that's
emotional I'm just kidding it's not but
but you know what I'm saying yes they
want here's what they want do you have
kids
I do have two kids geez yes they don't
want to lose their grandkids and so they
will do everything they can including
coming up with color-coded mental health
charts to help you stay
yeah that's right I figure and and to
put a kicker on it um my my
father-in-law just got diagnosed with
stage four cancer and he's going through
chemo so it's like there's a lot of
guilt
um involved in in this decision we don't
we're kind of at this weird Crossroads
and it's really hard yes
it's okay if someone right the second
isn't the time to go
that's okay
what I think you and your wife need to
do is to back out of this whole thing it
pause on everything back all the way up
because she's also going to be grieving
and her dad has a terminal cancer
diagnosis
step out of the whole thing
get somebody to come over and watch your
kids for half a day and y'all go to a
really nice restaurant in the morning
and y'all say okay what do we want our
life to look like for the next five
years
yeah
and if dad's got a prognosis that he's
gonna not be able with us for in six
months then let's consider sitting
around for six months and helping out
yeah
I don't know that you need to go knock
on the door and have some Grand
conversation about
um
you all have too much influence in our
life and blah blah all that kind of
stuff
a simple well hey let's let's take a
look at your bank income statements and
you a simple uh no thank you I want to
keep those personal
that suffices
okay and when you say things like well
we're both just people Pleasers that's
passing the buck just say no
okay and yeah remember this line choose
guilt over resentment every time
okay okay you're gonna feel because
you're all about people Pleasers you're
gonna feel guilty anytime you put up a
boundary
also don't not tell the full truth
because it it's easier
okay
all right so when me and my wife moved
here I had a like a world-class
professional opportunity at a
world-class University it's my dream job
if I got fired today I would they I
would love to go back to my exact job
they were amazing okay and and my wife
and I were very clear we wanted a new
adventure
we'd both been born and raised in the
same stay we've been in the same city
for 15 years or plus it was time for us
to go try a new adventure
and we told everybody that that way
there wasn't this like well what about
the job and when I went in to say hey
I'm transitioning out and they're like
well you want to negotiate to stay I
there wasn't this big drawn out
negotiation because it was only part of
the reason I wanted to go
yeah
and so I want you and your wife to be on
the same page because my gut tells me
the other half of this conversation is
is she is so used to listening to them
she likes the idea of not listening to
them but she's still going to do
whatever they say
yeah
is that part of it too yeah there's a
lot of uh well she's even more of a
people pleaser than I am and she kind of
shuts down when she gets into these
tough times conversations and we we both
kind of like uh just kind of nodder nod
our heads and just kind of accept what's
what's happening and what people tell us
to do yeah
at some point you've got to
you'll have to grow up and be in adults
both of you
yeah and you can't continue to let your
mom mommies and daddies run your life
um you have to decide what's best for
our family what does our family want to
do
and do we have some responsibilities I I
think helping out with if if she is the
only child I think helping out with
stage four cancer dad is Noble I I would
I would delay moving if you don't have
to
um
also I'm not going to give Financial
records to my in-laws and I love my
in-laws but if my mother-in-law said hey
send me all of your tax return I'm not
gonna I'm not sending that I wouldn't
give that to my parents it's mine it's
me and my wife that's ours and my
accountant and one buddy I have that I
trust with those hard conversations
because he gives me some some brutal
wisdom but other than that they're just
mine and so I I'm
or let's do this shift your
people-pleasing
to you
and to your wife
start there if you're gonna please
people if you have to please somebody
seek seek and say what's best for us
right now what's going to bring us joy
and then
how can we love and take care of the
people around us because now we're able
to do that because we filled our picture
up so anyway thanks for the call man do
not enter into transactional Financial
relationships with your family that is
the sure way to burn the whole
relationship to the ground
they want to give you money with no
strings and you choose to take it great
that's fine
um if you want to move just because
you're tired of living where you live
you want to go try a new place you want
to go back home with your family great
go for it but you and your wife
you and your wife need to be on the same
page talking the same language with the
same crystal clear picture of what
tomorrow's gonna look like
we're gonna take a half day go spend the
day together and dream big weep together
weave together and walk away with a plan
here's what the next one two three years
is gonna look like and then hang on
brother because it comes fast I'll be
right back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
feel like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show what you'd like to see more of what
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show Rocco
all right let's go to Maria in Denver
let's what's up Maria
hello John I am very very nervous don't
don't don't be you're good
haven't lost a patient yet what's up
actually you're not my patient but you
know what I mean what's up
so I am 25 years old with three kids
holy smokes we divorced
why yeah why'd you get divorced
um we were high school sweetheart we
um I know I'm just kidding I'm jealous
I'm jealous
no
it's a very weird scenario we didn't
quite know each other when I ended up
pregnant okay
um she ended up being a prom baby so
um awesome I know great and then three
months after I found out I was pregnant
I quite didn't know his family because
again it was kind of an oop and we
barely knew each other he left for the
military so
I had to go through the pregnancy pretty
much by myself up until two months prior
to me delivering the baby I had to get
to know his family all by myself
so that was great
um was it was it Maria was it girl was
it great
to my mother-in-law's at first
at the year is one by and I just really
disliked her okay
all right so you've got three kids three
little ones five and two Holy Smokes on
a stick all right so eight five and two
yes I got one kid asking you about sex
and you've got one kid who's still
babbling about in diapers and a
five-year-old who doesn't even know what
day it is so okay and you recently
divorced how recently is your divorce
finalized
um two months ago oh jeez it took about
a little over a year yeah Denver's the
worst man Colorado's the worst yeah it
got it got nasty lawyers
yes everything
um he accuses me of blind signing him
and that I messed him up and that
like he never seen it coming
but yet we did marriage counseling for a
year and a half
ultimately why'd you leave
um I was very alone okay
I pretty much did everything
you've been alone for a long long you've
been alone since you were in high school
right
oh yeah yeah
long long time
sorry I get very emotional about it what
are you talking about don't be sorry
about that you should if you were not
emotional about it I would think you are
weird
and I mean I come from
divorced parents myself yeah um
his parents are divided
divorce should be okay or they're
divorced they're non-divorced roommates
right yeah yeah
threaten each other
all right so you're here how can I help
what what can I help you with this is a
mess I'm so sorry I'm just heartbroken
with you
single the whole like my whole marriage
probably like two years
um
I did everything I mean we both worked
full-time he made great money he
definitely provided he was more of a
provider more than anything okay
um
he was super stressed out with his job
and I was like you know what take a huge
pick up that means our marriage will get
better
um he went to a much more relaxed job
nothing changed we would go to marriage
counseling
um it would fix the issues temporarily
um once I asked for the divorce
well he it all started he looks at me
and he's like you've been acting weird
these past three months and it's like I
just thought to myself why did it take
you so long to ask
I think that that's a good question but
it's also can be an unfair question
because you might not have been safe
person to ask that question to
or he may have felt you stressed and
thought the greatest gift he could give
you after watching his dad get
terrorized by his mom the greatest gift
he could give you a space
yeah and it may have been it took months
of Courage for him to go hey what what
is wrong I'm just speculating here but
those like he should have known I just
man I I don't like those kind of games
to be honest because it's like you
should read my mind I don't know how to
read your mind I tried to read your mind
you're doing the wrong thing it just
it's so much cleaner just to say here's
what I need
and that's yeah
go ahead go ahead
and I mean I feel like I've definitely
asked for it okay over and over again I
could be wrong
um I mean I definitely know I have my
fault
um
but when I asked for the divorce I guess
really what bugs me now is when I asked
for the divorce
he looked at me right away and he said
I'm never getting married again or ever
dating someone again
you already found somebody
like you're lying like I looked at him
and I said
you are 28. I was 24 23 at the time I
said we have a long life ahead of us we
are both going to find someone again
I said the only thing I ask is you don't
bring someone randomly into our kids
life right away I said date all you want
I'm perfectly fine with that
that's all I asked from him
so
filed for divorce
three months later
girlfriend starts showing up to our kids
soccer games and school activities
so does that break your heart yeah I'm
here like I I like and
are you mad that he moved on so fast are
you mad that he found somebody serious
so fat like what what what's what's the
what's the hole in your heart
what makes me so mad is like
like not giving that respect if that was
all I asked for
he may not see her as somebody random
or he may have been seeing her for three
years
we we get along on and off he's very
bipolar about it um
he he has told me that the only reason
he started dating her is because he
couldn't be alone
yeah okay
and I just you gave him some
you you would give him you gave him some
very unclear directions
some very amorphous directions
and my guess is that's been kind of the
Arc of your marriage which it's hard to
learn Clarity I'm terrible at it I'm
still learning how to do it so I still
see somebody it's hard
but hey just don't bring somebody random
that's like that's so unclear
yeah I want to meet the person that
you're dating and vet them before
they're around our kids that's clear
and I did I did
I did okay um
and
the only reason I found out prior
to him bringing her to soccer games
school stuff was I was driving we were
taking a road trip I was taking a road
trip with my kids and my oldest daughter
looks over at me and she's like we met
Dad's girlfriend and her family this
weekend
hmm
and I just I wasn't quite sure what to
say
so here's a hard question for you why
are you like you asked for a divorce
from him and you left
why are you still giving him access to
your heart in this way
ah
can I tell you that's that's an illusion
I mean
I was the one that always had to take
time off to watch the kids
um
he would rarely ever plan vacations with
him
and all of a sudden he's
so interested in their education and how
they're doing and their Sports and this
and that
can you celebrate the fact that he's not
a terrible absentee
father
because you got what you asked for and
now what you're asking for is you wish
time was different or you wish he had
been this way before which is fair
but you're still giving him access
instead of saying God thank God he
finally figured it out because this is
this this is the dad of my kids
would have been nice
if you'd been this way
and
I hear the saying like
um it sucks I asked for a divorce but
I'm thankful because now my kids get the
dab they deserve well that's a terrible
saying it's an awful thing I don't think
I would ever I don't think I'd ever be
grateful
with me yeah that's an awful saying
whoever came up with that saying should
stop talking
um
you were walking around here's the deal
you think something's wrong with Maria
h
and it was a mess wasn't it
it was yes
and it probably
I will say that you Maria are correct
you're correct
I started dating
this guy for
about well it didn't start off well and
it I should have known but I ignored it
I will say I ignored it here's why let
me let me get it because uh we're gonna
be up against the clock let me tell you
what's up
and again I am completely speculating
here
but your husband got a very Stark
consequence for his actions
and let's I'm just going to give them
the benefit of the doubt he lost
everything he lost his wife he lost his
home he lost the picture he had of kids
and he walked away maybe and said I've
got to change everything from the inside
out
because I don't ever want to lose that
again
and in this season it may not last it
may last forever hopefully it does
he said okay I want to find somebody
that I can do life with
and he's going to understand this is the
kind of data I'm gonna have to be moving
forward
and you are still trying to find
somebody that completes you that makes
you less alone
and that's an impossible burden to put
on somebody
you see what I'm saying
yeah
you're trying to find somebody to make
you feel a certain way
and that's that there's something wrong
with you and there is no human being
that you could date Brad Pitt it would
make you feel less weird for a few days
and then
it would come out in another way you'd
be super jealous of everything you
wouldn't be able to breathe it would
come out in another way because the core
issue here is Maria thinks something's
wrong with Maria
and Maria had a picture of what life was
going to look like and it was not 25
with three kids eight and under and no
husband
and I just feel like
I continuously
put my all into someone and I so you're
all into Maria
why won't you put your all into Maria
she deserves that much love too
she deserves that much joy too
she deserves that much connectivity and
and and fun and laughter
and she deserves the season of grief
that you're that you're desperately
avoiding
the season ahead of you if you want to
heal is not going to be pleasant because
you're going to have to sit in the fact
that I thought things would be different
and they are not
I want you with all of my heart I can't
make you of course but
I want you to call somebody today
and if you've been seeing somebody for a
long time maybe it's time to see
somebody new
and I think the first thing I would say
is
I've been playing catch-up on my life
since I was 18 years old when I got
pregnant at prom
and
I have been trying to live somebody
else's life for so long and I've run out
of gas
and I need to learn how to love Maria I
need to learn who Maria even is
I need to learn how to love and take
care of and honor and respect and treat
with dignity Maria
so that I'm filled up enough to take
care of my kids so that I am filled up
enough so that when I meet somebody
I won't have to be a vampire for them
take everything they've got trying to
fill me up
instead I can look at them and say how
can I best love you and then you get to
choose whether you want to do that or
not
and then you can say with your head held
high here's what it's going to take to
love me
all of that starts with Maria deciding I
love Maria enough
to make sure Maria's all right
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of on your past change your future
I want you to read that book
start to finish and I want you to call
the counselor and say I'm I need to
learn how new skills stop playing
catch-up all my life
to learn to love me we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back
um real quick
we've had more and more people call in
this year who are struggling with issues
in the workplace
since 2021 we've seen four million
people a month leave their jobs
political Economist Nicholas eberstadt I
don't know his work but
um tells us there's seven million
able-bodied men opting to sit at home
collecting
um checks instead of working seven
million have just said I'm out I'm out
my guess is there's more than that in
different ways and this is just talking
about men not including the women
so why are people giving up on on work
there's a drift to mediocrity plague in
our culture because people don't find
meaning in their work anymore Decades of
bad leadership in Corporate America have
led to things like decreased engagement
quiet quitting the great resignation
productivity is down complacency is that
all-time high
um the the entitlement like this is just
what you give me like this is what I
should get it's tough it's tough
um and let's be honest people are
working four jobs and they can't afford
rent in their town that they grew up in
and they're just like this sucks I'm out
I just I'm just I'm out
some of you who are listening might be
stuck in the middle of us right now
as always I promise you there's hope
on May 4th I'm teaming up with Dave
Ramsey Ken Coleman Mike Rowe of Dirty
Jobs uh Michael Easter who wrote what I
think is one of the best books of the
last five or ten years called Comfort
crisis and we're going to be talking
about the state of work in America today
we're going to address the labor crisis
and give Business Leaders solutions for
how to find and hire the right people in
this environment and if you're not a
leader but you're trying to think what
do I want to do with my life why am I
feeling like this this is for you too
because it may be directed at here's how
to hire the right people and here's what
you're looking for but as somebody
looking for work it's going to give you
a road map to be the most incredible
candidate coming forward and some of you
got to look at the mirror make some hard
choices go see the counselor change your
marriage whatever you got going on it's
going to be a great event if you're a
business leader small business owner
who's struggling right now or if you're
somebody who is thinking I've I I don't
what do we what's the point what is the
point is this it is this how is this how
um capitalism ends is this it this is
for you this is a free live stream no
money it's free you can register by
visiting ramseysolutions.com
labor crisis
ramseysolutions.com
labor crisis as wrap up today's show one
of my favorite bands of all time in the
whole wide world
um I love my punk and I love my metal
but I'll tell you what I saw a band make
art on stage one time in a way that
silenced me
um just was stunned
um from the Great and Powerful Counting
Crows the song's called round here it
goes like this
step out the front door like a ghost
into the fog where no one notices the
contrast of white on white
in between the Moon and you the Angels
get a better view of the crumbling
difference between wrong and right I
walk in the air between the rain through
myself and back again where I don't know
Maria says she's dying to the door I
hear her crying why
I don't know if you want to be a poet
someday
go read Adam's lyrics of change your
life love you guys we'll see you soon
[Music]